happy deathday to you is once again
directed by Christopher Landon and stars
Jessica Roth as tree and she finds
herself trapped once again in a never
ending time loop where she's murdered
over and over by someone in a baby mask
the difference this time though is that
some things have changed about the day
some of them are minor and some of them
are really drastic and so she has to
once again figure out how to defeat this
thing similar to the first film this is
more of a comedy than it is a horror
movie in fact more so even they've
really doubled down on the comedy
there's purposefully cheesy montages
with pop songs similar to the first but
in this one the horror has been
relegated to mostly just creeping around
hallways holding a weapon waiting for
somebody to burst out of a corner just
about every time the film tries to get
scary it goes for that old formula
somebody is creeping through a hallway
and they're nearing a corner and the
music is building to a crescendo and
there's nobody there and now the
person's behind them that's about the
limit of this film scare factor there
really isn't that much of any it's
definitely going far more for comedy and
in that aspect the film succeeds more
often than it fails namely because of
Jessica Roth she is the glue that holds
this movie together she's charismatic
giving a performance that's crazy high
energy she's so terrific in this movie
and she's great in the emotional scenes
to which this film has a surprising
amount of there's one choice that's made
in the film that I thought was really
effective and I can't get into it cuz it
is a spoiler but it's a way they switch
up things from the first because now
she's in this new environment that she's
unfamiliar with I don't want to get too
much into that just in case you didn't
watch any of the trailers cuz I tried to
stay away from them but she has to deal
with things that she didn't expect I'll
put it that way and that aspect of the
film I thought added a lot to her
character and it provided a really
interesting moral dilemma at the center
of her story in regards to a choice that
she has to make and I thought that was a
lot deeper than your average horror
comedy because it actually gave the film
a considerable amount of heart but there
are times where the movie can overuse
that
third-act becomes a long series of
goodbye sequences that just drag on and
on to the point of absurdity actually
and there's some cringy moments too in a
lot of this drama some of it just is
purposefully cringy like people kiss in
slow motion and sparks explode all
around them like I get that that's
supposed to kind of be tongue-in-cheek
and a little bit funny but I just I felt
nothing I guess I don't know if I'm
emotionally dead inside but one of my
biggest issues with this film is a
direction it takes that the first film
didn't have this film focuses a lot more
on science whereas the first film was
more about emotion and feeling this
movie takes a more scientific approach
to it which does some interesting things
for trees day that she has to relive
over and over again it changes things it
throws a wrench so to speak in the
clockwork of her plans but then it just
keeps happening over and over again and
the film asks you to buy a lot of things
that I just don't buy and they wisely
choose to never show these scenes for
instance every single day tree has to
convince these four people that she's a
mathematical genius and she knows all
these equations that can help reverse
what she's going through and they all
have to just believe her and risk being
expelled from college to do so naturally
they don't show these sequences over and
over again because that would get
repetitive but the film just asks you to
have a considerable amount of suspension
of disbelief at times and it didn't
always work for me but just like the
first one jessica roth is so terrific
and she makes the movie watchable even
when it's not that great christopher
landon is a talented director and i like
a lot of things he does here but
whenever the film tries to be scary
it's just the most mainstream familiar
scenes you've seen a thousand times and
the comedy is a bit hit or miss and
sometimes the emotion gets so
heavy-handed that i just couldn't really
feel it because the movie kept beating
me over the head telling me to feel it
it's not quite as good as the first one
i think the idea of making it scientific
based was a bit of a mistake the
ambiguity of what was happening in the
first film was more in
this film's version of answers just kind
of makes me want to roll my eyes a
little bit and it also sets up a sequel
that I have no interest in watching and
I really hope was just kind of a joke
because I really don't want to watch the
sequel it sets up that being said I
admire this films riskiness it's got
some balls on it it's it's not like
other horror films that are out right
now I'm gonna give happy deathday to you
a sea I'll say this though I feel like
this movie will benefit if you just
watch the first one if you watch them
back-to-back it'll probably be a
stronger experience for you just seeing
this one
after having not seen the first for a
couple years that might make it a little
less interesting but Jessica Roth is
again she's the best part of the film
and I I think if you really loved the
first one you're gonna find things to
like I just didn't really like the
direction they took guys thank you so
much as always for watching look forward
to more reviews very soon and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]